once upon a time tom holland was best
known for starring in the stage version
of billy elliot in the 2012 disaster
flick the impossible of course that all
changed when the british actor appeared
in captain america civil war donning the
iconic spider-man suit to fight against
steve rogers what's up everybody marvel
fans everywhere thought holland
absolutely killed it as peter parker and
they also agreed he looked ripped as
everybody's favorite web slinger he
might have even made some of his
co-stars jealous for how well-liked he
was in the flick tom's a little
all right
tom has his own base cam
he has like an entourage it's a lot man
he's a lot to deal with but how did he
physically transform from a scrawny tot
into one of the world's most famous
superheroes here's everything you need
to know about how tom holland turned
himself into spider-man
shaking it into shape unlike a certain
actor who's best known for playing
star-lord tom holland was in great shape
long before landing the role of
spider-man he started out taking hip-hop
dance lessons in england as a kid and
went on to study ballet for two years in
hopes of landing the title role in billy
elliot in addition to helping him get
bigger holland's dance background has
really aided him as an actor he told
interview magazine i'm very happy i had
that training it's been so valuable to
my career and i've used it on almost
everything i've done since that
experience certainly came into good use
when he cross-dressed for lip sync
battle with exactly zero fear of losing
any dude cred hitting the mats
every avenger has his or her particular
skill set iron man flies and blast stuff
black widow does martial arts spider-man
climbs walls does flips and makes
olympic gold medalists look like old men
of course peter parker got his acrobatic
skills courtesy of a radioactive spider
bite tom holland on the other hand
gained his gymnastic abilities from
years of hard work dedication and
risking his neck
like his dancing history he credits his
stage work on billy elliot with his
earliest exposure to gymnastics
they trained me in gymnastics while i
was doing that show and it's just
something i kept up um
while finishing the show and for my
auditions for spider-man holland is also
into free running a form of parkour that
emphasizes creative expression in other
words it involves a lot of acrobatics
not to mention some semi-dangerous
stunts speaking with metro holland once
explained me and my mates go free
running all the time i've probably
jumped four meters onto grass and two
meters between buildings in addition to
keeping him agile and limber which is
essential if you're going to play the
wall crawler himself
holland's gymnastic abilities might have
helped him land the role of spider-man
in the first place during the audition
process he transformed what would have
been a run-of-the-mill screen test into
an eye-catching exercise of his flipping
skills
and i basically did like a somersault
into frame and then a somersault out of
frame i need them to know
that i've got some gymnastics abilities
and stuff considering tom holland is the
guy currently wearing the spidey suit it
looks like his acrobatic skills paid off
finally here we go
changing things up another training
technique tom holland has adopted to
swell up to spider-man's size is circuit
training this controversial exercise
involves wearing an elevation mask while
performing multiple sets of reps like
burpees or bicep curling one after
another with almost no rest in between
stations and that's not the only
experimental exercise he's tried he's
also given electronic muscle stimulation
a world along the way too and they put
pads on you and you work out while the
pads electrocute you
and it's it sucks it really really sucks
and while he had some trouble with it at
first i tell you i did it once and i
didn't go to the toilet for two days
he's since given it another go hopefully
with less troubling consequences
punching it out if you want to be an
avenger sooner or later you're going to
have to throw down with some bad guys
luckily holland is big into combat
sports not only is he an mma fan showing
up at ufc events he also spends quite a
bit of time in the gym learning all he
can about the sweet science as a result
holland totally knows what he's doing
when he pulls on a pair of gloves my
mind's not blown
when he's not punishing those punching
bags holland also does every other gym
activity imaginable including chin ups
side lateral raises and even borrowing
thor's hammer to beat on some massive
tires so perhaps one of the most
effective elements of his workout regime
is how consistently he hits the gym
while still mixing up his routines
oh that was awesome
you might know michael b jordan from any
number of scene stealing roles like
steve montgomery in chronicle
but chances are you've never seen him as
fit as he is in his most recent movies
the actor put on some serious muscle to
convincingly play the son of a legendary
boxer in creed and a villainous
revolutionary in black panther so how
did he get so swole here's a look at how
michael b jordan got ripped for
hollywood
creed
while he's always been fit jordan had to
get seriously buff when he took the
title role of adonis creed in the 2015
boxing flick creed playing the son of
legendary boxer apollo creed from the
rocky films required jordan to take
things to the next level which he did
with the help of professional trainer
corey kaye in order to properly portray
a boxer jordan had to train like a boxer
that meant 45 to 60 minutes daily of
cardio along with tons of ab workouts
like crunches mountain climbers leg
raises reverse crunches and traditional
sit-ups to build up his core and burn
fat as for building muscle caye had
jordan focus on supersets exercising
where lifting or curling dumbbells are
interspersed with push-ups or another
workout and after that three full hours
of boxing training this ain't your
normal workout this is a rocky style
workout all told jordan packed on 24
pounds of muscle over a year of training
according to kaye it was hard going at
first when we first started he could
barely bench 20 pounds his legs were
flailing everywhere he had nothing he
used to hate all this jordan agreed
saying i felt muscles i didn't even know
i had it worked though so jordan brought
caie along with him to help add another
20 pounds of muscle in order to play the
super villain eric killmonger in black
panther but that's not all jordan did in
order to get ready for his big marvel
moment
nutrition nutrition nutrition
as any fitness buff worth his salt will
tell you exercise is only half the
battle when it comes to getting your
body into peak shape for jordan to get
into literal fighting condition he had
to cut his food intake almost entirely
to lean proteins carbs green veggies and
protein shakes according to jordan i
stripped down my diet completely i
worked out two to three times a day six
days a week and if you do that
consistently for about 10 months your
body will change don't worry though
because on the seventh day jordan rested
as kaye allowed him to cheat on his diet
once a week with french toast in the
morning philly cheesesteaks in the
afternoon and pizza yum
self-motivation is key
jordan told vice sports he credits
growing up in newark with a supportive
family as the inspiration for his work
ethic and aspirations my dad used to
tell me all the time i gotta be serious
about something that motivation has been
absolutely key to jordan's physical
transformation pushing him to heavier
weights and longer runs no matter how
painful the workout jordan can persevere
thanks to that motivation i told myself
at a young age that i was gonna like
sacrifice i used to run myself into the
ground to like pure exhaustion just
because then i'll feel like oh i deserve
it also providing motivation the results
jordan told men's fitness you know at
first you're hurting but when you start
bench pressing 225 pounds 10 times and
it ain't nothing and then you start
giving hugs to girls and they're like
feeling you up a little so i learned to
love it when i started seeing results
method training
being in fighting shape from creed
definitely helped jordan transition to
the training for black panther where he
used a new technique called method
training the technique adapts jordan's
workouts to match what his character
would do to stay in shape helping
alleviate the dreaded workout boredom
those workouts included a comprehensive
weapons training program in addition to
learning various forms of martial arts
for jordan it was a real departure from
the boxing focus training of creed
jordan told collider this one is more
martial arts using a lot of your legs so
i'm picking up different fighting styles
also a lot of guns too the weapons
training is a totally different muscle
no rest for the wickedly fit while any
normal person might want to take a break
from non-stop workout routines and just
eat some pizza and drink some beer
jordan is jumping right back into
training for creed 2. the story will
follow adonis creed fighting the son of
ivan drago the man who killed apollo
creed in the ring in rocky iv
professional boxer florian montano will
be playing the son of ivan drago and at
six foot four and 245 pounds jordan has
his work cut out for him but if there's
one thing his training has proven so far
it's that jordan isn't afraid of a
little hard work
henry cavill's good looks and strong
voice make him a natural fit to play
superman but getting into god-like shape
to play the last son of krypton is a
superhuman feat in and of itself how
exactly did cavill make himself faster
than a speeding bullet and more powerful
than a locomotive let's find out
exclusive jim
in order to turn himself into the man of
steel henry cavill turned to the
exclusive jim jones an invite-only gym
known for training athletes military
personnel and the cast of 300 jim jones
is not your warm and cosy neighborhood
pilates studio the gym prides itself on
having no televisions and no machines
and no mirrors and no comfortable places
to sit and apparently their walls have
seen a fair share of breakdowns both
physical and psychological
pushing limits
cavill's training regimen essentially
pushed him into the realm of the
superhuman he explained i'm training two
and a half hours a day pushing my body
beyond its normal limits it's not just a
physical thing but a psychological thing
as well cavalry called to shortlist one
particularly excruciating moment with
his trainer mark twight during which
cavill said he was doing some horrible
rowing sprint thing and i said i can't
do this mark i can't i'm done and he
said no you're not don't listen to the
lies i kept on pulling and pulling until
suddenly i realized i'd finished
strong foundation
getting big is one thing staying
superman sized however is an entirely
different story
yeah well you know
gotta up the game every year
henry cavill's twice daily training
sessions may have helped him get jacked
but once filming actually started that
regimen went out the window still the
man of steel was able to minimize the
detrimental effects of a reduced to
workout regimen thanks to the ultra
solid muscle base it built twight
explained stable fitness requires a
wider solid foundation the deeper that
foundation the more stable that
condition will be and the easier it is
to maintain
catching z's
before caval even started training twice
laid down one extremely important
stipulation the actor needed to get nine
to ten hours of sleep every single night
for five months twight explained to
muscle and fitness if you don't get the
sleep if you can't recover then we can't
continue with this training and we won't
achieve the objective the hgh and
testosterone secretion that happens
during these deep sleep cycles is super
important
tailpipe
caval's trainer highly recommends ending
any superman workout with something he
likes to call the tailpipe which was
given its name because as dwight says
quote when you're done it feels like
you've been sucking on the tailpipe of a
car basically you rode 250 meters at
full speed then hold two 24 kilogram
kettlebells in the rack position and
repeat three times after that your lungs
will certainly feel the burn and you'll
be able to get more out of each
subsequent workout thanks to the
increased lung capacity and stamina
can't skip cardio many people looking to
bulk up don't get in enough cardio which
does a lot more than just make you
faster than a speeding bullet caval
strength coach michael blevins explained
to men's fitness there's a misconception
that cardio will negatively impact
muscle a larger work capacity can allow
you to train harder and longer building
muscle without conditioning is akin to
having an impressive engine without a
gas tank it's worthless
brazilian jiu jitsu one of caval's
favorite ways to stay in shape is by
practicing brazilian jiu-jitsu however
the actor doesn't just dabble in the
martial arts he trains with the best
cavall frequently takes lessons from
ten-time jiu-jitsu world champion hodge
gracie in an instagram post he wrote my
bjj has slipped by the wayside a bit
with my focus being on work but it's now
time to get back into it such an
enjoyable way to train
chow down
while training to become superman cavill
would generally eat between 3 500 and 5
000 calories per day including regular
post-workout shakes he explained you've
got to eat protein first then a little
bit of carbs you've got to keep your
hunger levels going unfortunately a
guinness is what i crave so it's not
ideal for the six-pack abs getting 5000
calories meant roughly six meals per day
henry cavill.org list samples of the 3
500 and 5 000 calorie meal plans on
their man of steel workouts and diet
page
strength of character
anyone can hire some skilled personal
trainers and put down a bunch of
calories to get ripped but playing
superman requires more than simply
lifting heavy objects and exhibiting
lightning speed being superman requires
inner strength dwight told muscle and
fitness genuine accomplishment looks and
feels different it cannot be faked by
doing physically difficult things by
changing his body of his own will henry
changed his attitude and his bearing he
looked huge he walked huge his attitude
broadcast his physical capability
if you want to play a costume superhero
then you need to look the part and that
means intense workouts coupled with an
insane diet let's take a look at how
zachary levi went from super geek to
superhero and got ripped for shazam
[Music]
when zachary levi agreed to take on
shazam as his next big role he
essentially agreed to make the gym his
second home after all this is a
character who has stood his ground in a
number of scraps with superman over the
years if this confrontation is ever
going to play out on the big screen then
levi has to at least keep pace with
henry cavill assuming cavill is still
playing the man of steel by the time a
crossover is viable the movie's official
synopsis even described shazam as having
a ripped god-like body so there's little
wonder levi began hitting the weights
almost every day during a chat with
former smallville lex luthor actor
michael rosenbaum levi said he's working
out five or six days a week he
elaborated like sometimes we'll do two a
days and then we'll get more off days
but typically we'll just go you know
hour and fifteen minute sessions every
day that's a lot of time in the gym no
matter who you are and all that time
pumping iron definitely shows
when someone who doesn't work out
regularly starts hitting the gym hard
they usually experience what's known as
newbie gains
yes you two can have a body like mine if
you're not careful
this was evidently the case for levi who
managed to pack on an impressive amount
of pounds within his first six weeks of
training he told rosenbaum in february
2018. before i got the roll i was about
200 pounds i hovered around 200 pounds
most of my adult life levi gave a
similar account of his early gains when
variety caught up with them almost a
year down the line speaking to the
hollywood trade at the new york city
premiere of the marvelous mrs maisel
season 2 the actor revealed that he'd
started seeing results right away i
immediately put on about 24 pounds and
then we carved that down in about half
so i've been hovering around 215 pounds
and i'm in the best shape of my life and
stronger and happier and healthier than
i've ever been what's going on oh well i
i got into really good shape
am i hitting the light right
what
what's happening why why
it probably won't surprise you to learn
that levi had to consume a heroic amount
of calories to achieve a shazam worthy
physique when variety quizzed him about
his weight gain at the marvelous mrs
maisel season 2 premiere the actor
revealed that he'd been taking on
between 3 000 and 4 000 calories a day
ever since he won the lead role in the
dc movie let me just walk down this
peanut brittle real quick
why would you do that all right cause
calories
levi went on to give a more detailed
breakdown of his shazam calorie count
during his appearance on michael
rosenbaum's podcast 3 700 calories with
37 then like a bunch of other
supplements like fish oil omega-3 it's
an impressive amount of calories for
sure but how does it match up against
levi's dc counterparts the short answer
is that well it doesn't both ben affleck
and henry cavill reportedly consumed up
to 5 000 calories per day when training
to play batman and superman
levi described his diet as pretty lean
and clean and he really wasn't kidding
to achieve his body goals the actor had
to give up some of his favorite snacks
and make every single mouthful count
which is why most of his meals consist
of protein-rich chicken and large
portions of broccoli a favorite of
bodybuilders everywhere levi was even
eating broccoli for breakfast at one
stage documenting the experience on
instagram stories one bemused follower
took to twitter to ask the actor why he
would do such a thing and levi revealed
that he has a variation on chicken and
broccoli five times a day i basically
eat the same macros all day long meat
and veg varying combinations i used to
eat a lot of eggs in the morning but i
think i have an intolerance to them
hopefully that means he didn't have to
down any raw egg shakes rocky style
levi's physical transformation has
clearly been a source of inspiration to
his fans with some even reaching out to
ask the actor for hints and tips on
getting jacked he told one of his
followers it's a marathon not a sprint
i've been in the gym five days a week
for the last five months and i've eaten
pretty darn healthy strictly but not so
crazy that i'm not still enjoying life
the system works when another fan asked
how her skinny husband could look more
like levi the actor revealed that he
himself used to struggle with adding
muscle to a slender frame and it was all
down to diet according to levi you can
work out constantly but if you aren't
providing your body with all the right
tools then you're going to struggle to
improve on those newbie gains the former
chuck star replied the key i found was
quite literally consuming mass
quantities you have to feed your muscles
you have to give your body the building
material necessary to grow larger you
have to eat even when you're not hungry
14 000 calories later i found myself
down at subway
powering through a 12 inch veggie on
whole wheat
levi might advocate eating as much as
humanly possible but that doesn't mean
eating whatever you can get your hands
on when he was asked how he manages to
eat well while still enjoying his life
he gave a pretty straightforward answer
avoid processed foods from my
perspective the biggest favor you can do
for yourself is avoiding all processed
foods sweet or savory doesn't matter
it's all breaking down in your body is
sugar that is then stored as fat but
there's a lot of tasty clean food out
there get into it
why are you eating stem first this is a
new food for me how else should i eat it
the other way
junk food is far from the only obstacle
when you're trying to balance gym life
with the social life however alcohol
certainly doesn't help matters when
you're trying to remain as trim as
possible i'd like to purchase some of
your finest beer please
levi discovered the benefits of cutting
out the booze when he took part in sober
october 2018. star admitted it was a
little difficult at first and it's still
kind of strange not having a drink when
i go out at night but overall i feel so
much healthier and happier and clearer
of mind and heart it's been a good
cleanse may even take it longer we'll
see
finding the time to prepare five clean
meals a day can be a big challenge for
anybody let alone a busy actor but
that's where having a major hollywood
studio as your boss comes in handy levi
praised warner brothers for helping him
reach his targets when he spoke to
michael rosenbaum revealing that the
studio had arranged for his meals to be
brought right to his door he said oh
yeah i do meal delivery it's part of the
job and i and they've been they've been
very awesome about taking care of me
that's all well and good but what does
levi do when he's not home as an actor
he has to travel a lot but even then he
sticks to his regimented diet plan he
tweeted i use different meal delivery
companies in different cities because i
need to eat a lot throughout the day and
i don't know how to cook like at all
imagine putting yourself through months
of training and hundreds of portions of
broccoli only for one of the biggest
names in fitness to call you a fraud
that's the situation levi found himself
in during march 2018 when men's health
suggested that the actor was wearing a
padded suit on set some behind the
scenes photos of levi in full costume
were leaked online and regular
contributor vide mancuso took one look
at the size of levi's biceps and called
foul play in response to the men's
health investigation levi posted a
picture of his bicep on twitter along
with the caption so much padding it was
the actor's way of getting back at the
fitness mag but the author of the
original article wasn't convinced in
fact vinnie mancuso said the photo levi
posted was actually evidence that he was
correct about the suit padding all along
in a follow-up article he said yes that
is a large arm that is a gym earned
above average sized appendage but try to
tell yourself honestly that the arm in
that photo is the same arm in the leaked
photo you can't you just can't do it
levi has had a hard time shaking the
fake muscle rumors since his bat with
men's health some people seem to think
he looked padded out in a trailer that
dropped in january 2019 with one fan
questioning just how he looked so huge
the actor gave a purposefully
non-committal answer that's likely
because he's sick of addressing the
story by now when variety asked him
about it on the red carpet just a few
weeks earlier levi again denied that he
needed extra mass
especially in this area does that look
like fake does that look fake to you
come on
according to a study by the society of
behavioral medicine having a workout
partner can greatly improve your
performance in the gym doubling cardio
results in some instances while many
superhero actors are set up with
world-renowned trainers the guy spotting
levi is actually a photographer by trade
eric blackman has posted multiple pics
and videos of levi pumping iron
unofficially documenting the actor's
progress in october 2017 blackman
tweeted apparently i'll be getting
ripped for shazam as well since zachary
levi is kicking my ass in the gym i need
protein now despite the bleak winter
weather the pair remained dedicated to
the shazam cause as 2018 rolled around
by february levi was already looking far
more heroic in their sessions and by may
both men were looking fighting fit
levi replied to the second men's health
article with another photo of his guns
and this one was harder to argue against
the actor posted a topless pick of
himself in the gym along with a
hilarious equation it's like the old
saying goes hard work overtime plus
chicken and broccoli minus carbs divided
by whey protein in which x represents
the amount of supplements and y
represents the sentiment of why the hell
am i doing this to myself multiplied by
shameless selfies whilst staring into
nowhere talk about taking your workouts
to the next level why is this so hard to
understand this is not
string theory
when he spoke to variety in december
2018 levi was eager to discuss how being
selected to play the lead role in shazam
changed his life in more ways than one
his name is now known across the board
in hollywood and he likely picked up a
pretty paycheck for his work on the
shazam movie but he was also extremely
grateful for the chance to get healthy
honestly that's the stuff that i'm most
ecstatic about just the level of health
that i've gotten to mental health
emotional health spiritual health
physical health i am so jazzed about
that and i want to keep talking about
that particularly mental health it would
have been easy for levi to give up after
men's health suggested that he just
wasn't big enough to play a superhero
but he wasn't working out for anyone but
himself he added i just feel like we're
in a place particularly nowadays where
people need to be encouraged and
informed on what self-love is and to go
and genuinely embrace themselves and
love themselves so i'm really happy
about all of that sorry
i
just had to reboot
as the star of one of the most
long-lived superhero film franchises
hugh jackman has been contractually
obligated to keep his body in a near
constant state of shreddedness since
1999. that's just how it goes when
you're famous for playing a character
whose costume often consists of one pair
of adamantium claws and a veiny pair of
pecs but how did jackman transform from
a six foot two 180 pound bean pole into
the muscle-bound wolverine he is
everything that goes into making and
maintaining his incredible physique he
never skips the gym if you've been
watching jackman play wolverine since
the very beginning you might have
noticed that he hasn't just kept himself
in shape he's clearly set out to make
each of his appearances even more
physically intimidating than the last
when jackman first showed up in 2000's
x-men he looked good but in an
achievable way like your friend from
work who goes to the gym in the morning
and only drinks light beer celebrity
trainer david kingsbury revealed
jackman's formula for success and it
involves going to the gym six days a
week twice a day the actor follows a
four week workout cycle when he's
planning to slip back into his
adamantium laced bones the first three
weeks are all about lifting heavy and
pushing huge amounts of weight for only
a few repetitions the fourth week
jackman deloads and lifts smaller
amounts but at a higher volume which
stimulates muscle growth so that he'll
be as big as possible on screen the
whole thing is pretty much murder on his
wardrobe there's boxes in my storage
fat suits skinny suits normal suits
and um and right now in this shape i
don't have any suits jackman told the la
times that there's one thing that he
favors above all when it comes to
transforming his body for a new x-men
movie the deadlift and that's not just a
clever pun
he eats all the food
when it comes to building a screen ready
physique your workouts are less than
half the battle yeah you gotta try and
you gotta train hard but if you don't
eat right none of them matters to get
wolverine style muscles jackman has to
seriously shovel it in jackman told
men's fitness i eat more but i eat a lot
stricter 70 of your physique is your
diet and diet is the biggest change that
happens there were times when i would
literally eat with the mindset of
working out one more mouthful one more
come on come on you've got to finish
this meal the actor's x-men diet of 6
000 calories per day was recommended by
a guy who knows a thing or two about
getting buffed for a role yeah i
literally rang dwayne johnson the rock
man i've seen you in some movie i said
what's going on what do i do and before
you go thinking that this doesn't sound
so terrible keep in mind that jackman's
superhero diet is high in calories but
low in carbs which means that he has to
get those 6000 calories primarily in the
form of grilled chicken breast spinach
and the occasional scoop of brown rice
though jackman was seen celebrating with
some very undiet-like foods after logan
finished filming
he uses what nature gave him before you
spend the rest of your life weeping into
a bowl of buttered popcorn over the
unattainable awesomeness of hugh
jackman's abs know that getting a body
like his isn't just a question of
chicken breast bicep curls and
impeccable jeans jackman's trainer
explained that the actor's diet and
training regimen included the use of
creatine a supplement that stimulates
muscle growth beyond what the body can
accomplish on its own he explained we
used a pre-workout product called animal
pump while bulking we used creatine in
the product and when cutting we reduced
and then removed the creatine it's not
exactly the weapon x program even the
strictest anti-doping regulators are
cool with the use of creatine and it's
been a regular item on the menu for
bodybuilders and athletes since the
1990s but it is one of the reasons why
you don't look like a wolverine despite
your best efforts
broadway bud
jackman is a stage actor first and
foremost with a background on broadway
he'd be the first to tell you that
wolverine for all his exceptional
talents would not be much of a dancer so
the actor doesn't hang on to his super
heroic physique when he's doing shows in
between superhero flicks he told the la
times when i dance i drop a muscle very
quickly the body is very smart and
efficient and a traditional dancer's
body is not going to be bulked up on top
because they are muscles you don't
really need while doing stage work may
cost jackman his biceps it also has the
benefit of keeping jackman in terrific
shape when the cameras stop rolling the
actor still stays busy and active and
doesn't let himself go so when it comes
time to bulk up berserker style he's
starting from a very good place
he stays accountable
getting in superhero shape isn't just
diet and exercise it's also a question
of mindset and motivation so where does
jackman get the mental fortitude to
endure the months of torture that
precede a new x-men flick he gets it
from you of course jackman always makes
sure his followers know when he's back
in the gym and that's not just because
he enjoys watching his instagram likes
rolling when you've talked to your fans
to expect photos and video of you doing
clap push-ups or dead lifting the weight
of a fat shetland pony you've got to
bring it at the gym or risk
disappointing them so when you follow
jackman on instagram and dutifully press
that little heart icon for his clips
from the gym you're doing your part to
make sure he shows up in logan looking
like a muscular nest of pythons with a
human head
josh brolin has been a formidable
presence in hollywood since he was a
teen but these days his body is getting
as much attention as his body of work
the acclaimed actor has packed on a ton
of muscle for an upcoming larger than
life role here's how josh brolin got so
massively jacked for his role as cable
and deadpool 2.
comically large
brolin's ascension to swolness began on
the page with the actor taking a few
drawings of cable to one of his personal
trainers to get specific about what he
wanted but here's the thing cable's most
well-known look was put together by rob
liefeld an artist whose work is
frequently defined by insanely pumped up
stylized and unrealistic body shapes
justin lovato a personal trainer and
bodybuilder who worked with brolin on
his look said to get even halfway close
to the insanely huge upper body cable
has in the comics brolin spent three
hours a day in the gym for six weeks
straight
killing the carbs brolin had to wean
himself off of carbohydrates to get cut
like cable and he wasn't happy about it
at first in one of many of his
inspirational instagram posts brolin
laid it all out cable's coming growing
from the inside clean building from a
past of donut travel to the present hard
case that he is no sugar no bread no
pastas the machine is being built i'm
pissed off in another post a recording
of an upper body workout he shared his
pride in going totally clean no drugs
none of it fish rice eggs veggies water
i'm almost 50. it's a different time our
access along with some big picture
discipline results in always surprising
milestones get on the train
cheap day to transform into cable brolin
says it required intense mental focus to
stay in a fit frame of mind but it's
also okay to have a cheat day as long as
it benefits that mindset this challenge
has been an awakening that there is no
excuse ever but there's no need for
perfection cheat days replenish and tell
your body it's okay it keeps it from
panicking which usually shuts it down
and ends up giving you a worse result
keep at it then when the day comes
murder that friggin donut
support network
of course no one gets movie star buff
without a little professional help and
brolin acknowledged that the progress he
made with his body is the result of a
team effort writing it takes a small
village in an instagram post tipping his
hat to his trainer and of course he
always has a shout out for katherine
brolin his wife business partner and
frequently the eye behind the camera for
his fitness clips on social media the
actor also finds encouragement through
fellow members of the thespian league of
muscle heads performers like
professional wrestler turned actor dave
bautista a man brolin calls his great
swole mentor brolin also related a
delightful encounter he had with the man
who plays drax the destroyer in a post
on instagram just saw dave batista at
the gym and he said what the [ __ ]
happened to you ha ha best compliment
ever
friendly competition
while positive encouragement is always
nice having a rival can be beneficial as
well encouraging a spirit of competition
brolin has gotten plenty of that
motivation from deadpool 2 co-star ryan
reynolds who tagged social media photos
of cable hashtag premium cable and
hashtag maximum
for his part brolin is more than capable
of firing back on instagram he shared a
photo of the two stars side by side on
competing magazine covers ryan reynolds
smart ass secrets or josh brolin's
beating his demons to become hollywood's
go-to hellraiser it's just not fair
on brand along with his wife catherine
the actor recently launched an
activewear clothing line prevail which
he promotes in his workout posts and
frequently sports it's not just for his
own bottom line either the limited
edition cable swoll line of t-shirts
tank tops and hoodies benefits
organizations like the saint jude's
children's research hospital so in
addition to keeping him healthy getting
swole for deadpool 2 has also helped the
49 year old raise money for charity and
promote the family business
double duty brolin is not only getting
ripped to play cable he's also staying
fit to once again play thanos in
avengers infinity war yes thanos is
largely cgi and makeup but the wizards
in marvel will also be putting as much
of brolin's physical performance on
screen as they can through the process
of motion capture fortunately brolin's
done the hard work and the whole world
will get to see the fruits of his labor
when the one-two punch of a new avengers
movie and deadpool 2 hit cinemas in
2018.
as one of the six original avengers
scarlett johansson has been playing
black widow otherwise known as natasha
romanov for the better part of a decade
but being one of the fittest forces in
the mcu didn't come easily at all
scarlett johansson made her mcu debut
back in 2010 when she first portrayed
black widow and iron man 2. since then
she's had to maintain a high level of
fitness following the release of
avengers end game in april 2019 her
personal trainer eric johnson told the
hollywood reporter scarlett always wants
to be within three weeks out of her peak
condition of course she's taken on
plenty of other physically demanding
roles outside of the marvel universe
like her roles in lucy and ghost in the
shell as she told e news getting herself
in fighting shape for ghost in the shell
was no walk in the park going to the gym
eating clean and and working a long day
and then going to bed and sleeping well
and getting up and doing it again the
next day even though johansen was a
total stranger to the gym when she was
cast as black widow it sounds like
they're old friends now and she told the
hollywood reporter the gift of fitness
has been one of the best parts about
working for marvel i'm stronger and more
capable now than i was 10 years ago so
how did she go from being a total noob
to getting totally ripped as her trainer
eric johnson points out black widow is
no ordinary role we're trying to create
this crazy comic book hero in real life
with someone who's normal the workout
routine is truly extraordinary let's see
if you think you can handle it
the actress has been training with
johnson since 2009 but working out
didn't necessarily come naturally to her
in 2019 johnson told the hollywood
reporter that her first rope climb was
something of a disaster on the way up
she kneed me in the face and gave me a
nice bloody nose she was celebrating and
i'm fighting back tears gushing blood
but she learned quick johansen was
reportedly way more competent by the
time she filmed the avengers according
to hollywood stuntwoman hiding
moneymaker incidentally heidi's sister
renee is also a stunt woman
yes that is our real last name we were
born with it
in 2012 heidi told shape magazine
johansen is one of my favorite actresses
i have ever worked with she works very
hard and picks things up really fast
scarlett johansson developed a great
relationship with heidi moneymaker right
off the bat strictly speaking moneymaker
was hired to do things johansson
couldn't and wouldn't do but in the end
moneymaker taught the actress that she
could do a lot of the stunts herself
heidi was like my beacon of hope she
like lit the way and she was incredible
heidi is so creative in her movement and
all the movements really tell a story
when the pair reconvened for 2012's the
avengers they took their working
relationship to the next level and
squeezed in sneaky workout sessions
between takes with hand-hand combat and
weapons training on the agenda it was
still hard work money maker told shape
scarlett is such a professional and
works incredibly hard so she learned all
her fights and performed them with
perfect execution
the words bodybuilding and veganism
don't usually go hand in hand but more
people are discovering just how
beneficial the diet can be while
training including thor actor chris
hemsworth the stacked aussie star went
vegan while training for 2012's the
avengers man so did johansen well almost
according to johansen's former trainer
bobby strum the actress was on a quote
mostly vegan diet at the time in an
interview with ikaratsi johansen quipped
after lots of fighting and training and
raw vegan food you can fit into a cat's
suit she ate lots of kale as she tried
to get fit for the first avengers film
but when the shoot was done so was the
vegan diet she confessed to fox news
buffalo chicken wings i am addicted to
them
scarlett johansson's next appearance as
black widow came in 2014's captain
america the winter soldier starring
alongside super ripped actor chris evans
is likely to make even the most
confident performer feel inadequate but
johansen clearly rose to the challenge
talking to elle in 2013 she revealed i
like lifting weights and doing exercises
to work my core muscles to be honest i
work out like a guy it's this heavy
focus on weightlifting paired with her
strict diet that gets johansson where
she needs to be johansson told access
hollywood it's boring 5 am workouts and
salad and chicken and nothing else
pretty much it's that old tried and true
work out like a dude and eat like a
rabbit johansson also followed that
routine when it was time to get in shape
for 2015's avengers age of ultron we
picked up the same program we'd used for
iron man 2 and it had a proven history
scarlett johansson took a rather extreme
approach to training for avengers
infinity war and end game in an
interview with harper's bazaar her
trainer eric johnson revealed johansen
would often fast for 12 hours a day
sometimes even longer at moments we
pushed beyond that to 14 to 15 hours
depending on the filming schedule
johnson spilled even more dirt on
johansen's diet to the hollywood
reporter claiming johansson dropped
carbs in the days leading up to the
shoot in order to get some extra
enhancement on our cuts that's just the
kind of ruthlessly sneaky maneuver we'd
come to expect from black widow isn't it
i adore you
[Music]
actor tom hardy often portrays
characters that are dangerous cold and
calculating that makes him the perfect
choice to play venom the slimy anti-hero
at the center of marvel's spider-man
are
spin-off
hardy seems to have the ability to
physically transform himself for any
role here's a rundown of his most
remarkable transformations over the
years all of which helped him get the
physique necessary to play venom
dropping weight for stuart tom hardy is
far from a natural athlete he's admitted
to feeling small and skinny and
vulnerable as a child and was
intimidated by the gym because of all
the testosterone his first dedicated
physical transformation began with the
2007 biopic stewart a life backwards
hardy lost a whole lot of weight to
portray stuart shorter a homeless heroin
addict with muscular dystrophy he lost
almost 30 pounds for the role but took a
relatively healthy approach to his body
transformation hardy worked with a
personal trainer ran several miles a day
and kept a diet rich in protein
including eating as much spinach and
greens as he wanted
fortunately for his sanity the training
and diet regimen only lasted five or six
weeks
bulking up for bronson when he began
training for the lead role in bronson
hardy needed to pack on serious weight
he told i love film i probably weighed
about 11 stone with like drenched with
with stones in my pockets to play the
notoriously violent criminal hardy only
had five weeks to bulk up using a bare
bones workout routine hardy managed to
miraculously put on seven pounds a week
his trainer ex-marine patrick peanut
monroe added lots of variations to his
workouts making every rep difficult in
one way or another
a solitary physique you know the kind of
physique you would you would develop if
you only had
four walls and a floor
upping intensity for warrior
for his next film warrior tom hardy
demonstrated impressive discipline while
preparing for his role as a marine
turned mma fighter hardy packed on slabs
of lean muscle to convincingly portray a
professional athlete and his daily
training regimen was tough he even
lifted weights with his teeth to build
neck muscles you heard that right so it
was like two hours boxing two hours
kickboxing
muay thai then uh two hours choreography
a day and then two hours lifting every
day the actor ate five or six
high-protein meals per day and wound up
29 pounds heavier than when he trained
for bronson beefing up for bane
to play the masked villain bane in the
dark knight rises hardy needed to appear
larger than life which he achieved by
packing on even more size prior to
shooting party appeared on chatty man
and opened up about the physical demands
of the roll once again i'm going to go
up to about 13 or 14 stone and i'm 12 in
a bit now
so i've got and three months to do that
how did you bulk up fat a lot of fat
packing on 30 pounds brought hardy's
weight up considerably he was almost 200
pounds by the time filming began
but as he told jonathan ross that still
wasn't enough to intimidate christian
bale on the first day of shooting and i
looked at him and he was looking at me
like
oh yeah
losing mass for max
in order to play the title character in
mad max fury road hardy had to lose 30
pounds the same amount of weight he
gained to play bane he told collider he
wanted to look like a hungry wolf or
like when you put a cat in the bath
hardy reached his goal in a surprising
way by smoking cigarettes and eating
only one meal per day once the weight
was dropped the next step was three or
four months of fight training hardy
didn't exactly have time to rest when
cameras were rolling either he told
men's fitness
and it's a very physical shoot from the
beginning from the training right
through to the six months of shooting on
the ground
finding his inner venom by the time
venom started filming in october 2017
hardy was already a master at
transforming his body he got ripped for
the role by applying tools he'd
accumulated over years of hard work with
no quick fix or magic ingredient he
required guidance from professional mma
fighter nathan jones and personal
trainer mark mean and trained in a
combination of boxing mma and kickboxing
he's a good student
receptive open to learning judging from
a sparring video jones posted on
instagram hardy adapted to the challenge
quickly listen i'm just setting the plan
tommy's doing the work hardy's got a lot
to live up to given venom's reputation
but considering the actor's ability to
fully commit to a role there should be
no doubts peter parker look out
chadwick boseman followed in the
footsteps of a whole host of elite
superhero actors by getting seriously
ripped for his role as t'challa in black
panther but his hollywood fitness
journey actually started well before he
joined the marvel cinematic universe
here's some insight into how chadwick
got chiseled
the path to panther t'challa is in
bozeman's first physically demanding
role in 2013 he portrayed jackie
robinson in the biographical drama 42 as
well as capturing robinson's off-field
contribution to the civil rights
movement bozeman needed to appear
authentically athletic for scenes on the
field to prepare bozeman trained twice a
day for three and a half months
following the same technique as the pros
in an interview with gq he referred to
the sessions as madness due to the
strain such activity places on the body
aside from swinging his hips and
shuffling bozeman's appearance as the
godfather of soul james brown must have
been a breeze compared to 42 right
wrong when portraying a musician as
influential as brown the pressure is on
not only to sound the same but to move
the same as well bozeman had to do the
splits while filming get on up not once
but 96 times the actor admitted that
day's shooting was harder than any
activity he performed as jackie robinson
secret training unlike some of his
fellow mcu stars bozeman has remained
tight-lipped when it comes to divulging
the secret of his regimen when asked by
e-news prior to civil war's release he
refused to share any inside information
for those looking to emulate his results
a lot of strength and flexibility but
i'm not going to say anymore i can't say
or reveal their training secrets though
bozeman hasn't disclosed the specifics
of his workout plan all actors in the
mcu are notoriously put through their
paces and he won't escape what captain
america himself chris evans refers to as
absolutely brutal sessions couple hours
a day and it was it was brutal uh the
tricky part was eating you have to eat
lunch just eating everything all the
time but the key to achieving bozeman's
lean physique likely lies more with the
classic bodybuilding techniques
including circuit training and a less
substantial diet that still adds power
to black panther's claws while evans
needed to pack on the pounds in a short
span of time bozeman's goal of remaining
lean meant he could increase his body
mass at a slower rate this meant an
extra emphasis on cardiovascular and
circuit training to burn more calories
for explosive movements bozeman would
focus on plyometric training which
increases power by working on fast
twitch muscle fibers combat work likely
tops it all off with training in a
variety of martial arts
losing muscle for marshall
sandwiched between performances as black
panther bozeman played thurgood marshall
in the 2017 biopic martial replacing
civil wars airport battles with clashes
in the courtroom
understandably bozeman would look out of
place as the future supreme court
justice if he maintained the mass so to
fit tailored trousers and well-fitted
blazers the actor needed to strip away
25 pounds of hard-earned muscle between
the rap on marshall and the beginning of
black panther's production in january
2017 bozeman needed to recover lost
muscle mass to ensure his shoulders
could carry the weight of expectation
for his return as t'challa with the
added spotlight and increased screen
time bozeman's training regimen will
presumably have been even more intense
than his civil war workout but the
principles will remain the same a
gradual progression of lean mass
sebastian stan may play a superhero on
the big screen but he's well aware that
the winter soldier's bionic arm can't
pull all the weight itself here's the
fitness routine stan used to get into
super heroic shape
just like the winter soldier himself has
changed allegiances over the course of
his time in the mcu sebastian stan's
fitness routine has undergone similar
alterations the actor sat down for an
interview alongside his trainer don
saladino in which he discussed how
landing the marvel role forced him to
reconsider how he was exercising prior
to getting the part he said i felt like
i was just doing what i think a lot of
people do you know when they're out
there it's just they just know to go to
the gym but you don't have a plan really
when he first done the mantle of the
winter soldier that's when things
started to change for captain america
the winter soldier he had a pretty
simple mission in mind to look good
shirtless clearly he achieved that goal
and then some but things started to turn
when he was set to reprise the role in
captain america civil war he may have
just wanted to look good for winter
soldier but for the sequel he said i
knew these guys were going to be massive
around me i was like let's just get as
thick as possible
throughout his time in these superhero
movies sebastian stan's chest has
regularly been on display this has
necessitated the actor to really focus
on that area of the body and his trainer
put together what's clearly an awesome
regimen to accomplish precisely that
saladino told men's journal i threw in a
lot of gymnastic movements before we
even started training before every
workout there was about 20 to 30 minutes
of functional movement fun bodyweight
exercises like this got us warmed up but
also got us excited to train from there
he goes into five minutes of handstands
five minutes of turkish getups five
minutes of arm bars and 5 minutes of
front levers stands routine and
transitions into two separate weight
blocks the first of which consists of
flat dumbbell presses dumbbell squeeze
presses and cable flies a second block
has him doing incline barbell presses
alternating flat dumbbell presses and
dips
the arms were another area that saladino
helped stand to develop the trainer told
men's journal the fact is biceps and
shoulders aren't a major muscle group so
i like to throw in an arm day when the
rest of the body isn't feeling up to
being pushed when you are trying to
build the arms i always like to start
with a heavy movement putting pressure
on the tissue there are two workout
standards on arm days the first is a
kettlebell carry workout which starts
with an overhead carry of 50 yards for
each arm he then goes into a rack carry
for 50 yards a bottom up carry for 50
yards a one arm suitcase carry for 50
yards and a farmer's walk of 100 yards
to finish it off to work out his arms
stan got into various forms of
weightlifting including tricep push
downs hammer curls skull crushers and
heavy barbell curls if anything the
results of this regimen may have worked
out too well stan told men's health that
when he got fitted for his prop arm for
captain america civil war it no longer
comfortably fit on him
when it comes to getting in shape what
you eat plays just as important to roll
as how much you're exercising for
sebastian stan that means sticking with
a diet that allows him to stay lean
while still packing up muscle mass and
according to fitness clone it involves
plenty of vegetables lean proteins and
healthy fats when training for his
winter soldier role stan tends to eat
once every two to three hours and avoids
anything that could undo all the process
he made in the gym including refined
sugars salts and commercial meats
perhaps it shouldn't come as a surprise
that stan doesn't really eat a
restaurant while he's training because
he can't really get anything that tastes
halfway decent on top of that stan makes
sure to get adequate sleep when he can
somewhere in the vicinity of 8 to 10
hours a night as it turns out sleep is
one of the best things a person can do
when trying to pack on muscle as it
accounts for a great deal of the body's
muscle repair and growth
it's one thing to look buff on camera
it's another thing entirely to put your
fitness regimen to the ultimate test to
perform fight scenes and ridiculous
stunts as it turns out stan is willing
to put himself wholeheartedly into his
role as confirmed by his stunned double
for the falcon and the winter soldier
john nunia during an episode of the
screen forum podcast the stuntman talks
about what a pleasure it was to work
alongside the actor for the disney plus
series there's gonna be quite a few
moments where it's more a lot of stand
than you're looking at doing certain
parts because he stepped up and he put
the training in from that point it was
like well we know he can do this let's
push it even further nania goes on to
tell the screen forum podcast i don't
think the winter soldier is quite over
with in the marvel universe there's
still a lot more to ride out on that one
and i look forward to being part of it
it may not be an official confirmation
of season 2 of the falcon and the winter
soldier but we'll take what we can get
at this point it's a lot of hard work to
play a super soldier but stan has proven
he's up for the challenge time and time
again
robert pattinson the world's newest
bruce wayne recently revealed that he's
in the process of buffing up for the
batman but what exactly does that
training measurement entail here's how
the english actor is getting ready for
his next big role
they say that abs are made in the
kitchen but revealed in the gym and
pattinson implemented a pretty
particular method of eating to build a
superhero physique in his own words
pattinson is an extremist when it comes
to his eating choices and that's all go
on a month-long junk food bender before
it comes time for him to drop weight
pattinson apparently took this approach
for the batman during an interview with
buzzfeed in october 2019 he claimed i'll
eat nothing but pizzas for months so by
the time i have to diet my body is like
thank god please only healthy stuff from
now he also mentioned that he had begun
a process of bulking up for the batman
for those unaware bulking is a common
dietary practice and can be done by
everyone from professional athletes to
actors prepping for a role to an
everyday person wanting to literally
bulk up their body either in preparation
for a muscle defining weight cut or
simply to keep extra pounds on their
frame in general there's no one right
way to bulk though two of the most
popular and well-known methods are clean
bulking and dirty bulking those who
practice a clean bulk gain mass by
eating a caloric surplus taking in more
calories than their basal metabolic rate
or bmr that's the total amount of energy
one expense simply by being alive a
clean bulk involves choosing healthier
foods to chow down on think oatmeal and
brown rice almond and peanut butter
proteins like salmon chicken and lean
beef and healthy fats like avocados
olive oil and full-fat coconut milk
those who dirty bulk on the other hand
smashing calories from all kinds of
sources the denser the better and from
its interviews that sounds like the
route pattinson took who's that man
is that a hot dog
new york hot dog it kind of makes you
fall in love
while his best friends at one point may
have been papa john and little caesar
pattinson has now adopted a cleaner diet
and has cut out more than just the carbs
in a feature for the health and fitness
magazine healthy for men it's noted that
pattinson cut down on alcohol and
reduces intake of processed meat in
addition to resisting the temptation of
fried foods all in the effort to get his
body into superhero shape giving a beer
and saying so long to something deep
fried may be difficult for us everyday
people but for pattinson and other
superhero actors it's all part of the
job and from the way he described his
pizza heavy phase his body probably
thanked him switching to a healthier
eating plan
for actors looking to change their
bodies for a film a fitness routine goes
hand in hand with their diet of choice
sometimes that involves very little
working out and a whole lot of pies
christian bale's combo of choice when he
was gaining weight to play former vice
president dick cheney in vice other
times it requires pushing a 5 000 pound
jeep across a parking lot and only
eating junk food as a reward for working
out which is what bree larson did while
prepping for captain marvel point is
exercise or lack thereof is just as
important as diet when it comes to
transforming your body pattinson's a
smart guy so he knows this thankfully
his new perspective on exercise made his
batman movie prep a lot easier while
speaking to interviewer margaret
gardiner joined the lighthouse press
circuit in the fall of 2019 pattinson
revealed that he was weirdly looking
forward to getting in shape for the
batman which is all thanks to his new
feelings about exercise he shared with a
laugh i didn't like exercise when i was
younger now as i've kind of gotten older
i'm suddenly getting aware of aging it's
like i need to put some effort in
otherwise i'm gonna need a hip
replacement the actor followed up on
that thought in a separate interview
with buzzfeed saying i used to hate
working out in my 30s i find it very
meditative it's weird when you feel like
someone's not forcing it on you and
you're doing it for yourself it's a very
different experience i'm really looking
forward to it
when the time came to put thoughts into
action and begin working out for the
batman pattinson kept his exercise
routine varied according to healthy for
men the actor would perform a 5-minute
cardio workout followed by a strength
training circuit consisting of crunches
side bends and other core work pattinson
also picked up a habit of regularly
running three to six miles three to four
times per week the actor also took up
boxing and had been spotted doing what
healthy for men called military style
sandbag routines likely to add
excitement into his exercise regime and
to increase strength and agility beyond
the standard gym stuff patenson took
time to unwind or still getting outside
and moving about taking long walks to
rest the body and soothe the mind sounds
like battinson will be one balanced dude
in interviews pattinson has opened up
about what it's been like to take on the
role of batman for the actor who's
received most acclaim for his turns in
drama that didn't require physical
transformations he knows looking like
bruce wayne is just as important as
acting like him he admitted that the
lockdowns that world governments imposed
on the face of the coronavirus pandemic
have impacted his progress but he's
determined to keep going and do his
absolute best as a new batman because
ultimately this has been an exciting
learning experience for pattinson he
told healthy for men in every project
i've ever taken on i've come into it
wanting to learn and to achieve new
things that's usually in the embodiment
of a character and someone who has a
different personality to me but taking
on a full physical transformation as
well feels even more exciting a few
years ago i would have run a mile from
anything with a physical edge pattinson
continued sharing that he does wonder
whether he can live up to expectations
in terms of both physicality and his
actual performance but he understands
that's normal plus he knows the honest
isn't entirely on him to look
unbelievably buff pattinson apparently
plans to continue getting ripped without
damaging his body and then let movie
making magic take care of the rest you
look at the true warriors of the
superhero genre hemsworth the rock
downey jr evans and wonder if you're
putting yourself in the wrong place and
yet having spoken to a few i know
everyone is nervous when the opportunity
comes about it's all about pushing
boundaries and building up to a point
where you know you can do justice to the
physicality required and past that so
much of it is letting the special
effects and on-screen exchanges produce
surreal magic overall it's just very
exciting fans can see the fruits of
robert pattinson's labor when the batman
hits theaters on october 1st 2021
the first couple of thor movies lacked a
little something at least when compared
to the likes of iron man and captain
america the winter soldier that all
changed when director taika waititi came
on board to helm thor ragnarok the third
installment to the series and a film
that completely changed what was
possible within the marvel cinematic
universe but tt will be coming back for
the sequel thor love and thunder and
based on everything we know about the
film so far he's going to take these
heroes in even wilder directions than
before in addition to having the
guardians of the galaxy player role jane
foster played by natalie portman is
returning to the superhero franchise
after being absent from ragnarok this
time around though she's not just
playing a love interest she's donning
the title of mighty thor herself and by
the looks of an exclusive behind the
scenes photo that looper obtained from
backgrid she's taking the part very
seriously but preparing for her big
superhero role by never skipping arm day
shouldn't come as a surprise to anyone
familiar with portman's career the
academy award winner has always gone
above and beyond to reflect the
characters she plays most famously she
actually shaved her head when her
character had to do the same in v for
vendetta but even that fails in
comparison to what she had to do for
black swan ballerinas naturally have to
be in exceptional physical condition to
dance the way they do and to properly
showcase the art form portman reportedly
trained six days a week for up to eight
hours a day so that she could really
dance like a ballerina her training
regimen there was obviously different
from what she's doing to become thor but
it's clear she has the perseverance to
adhere to any workout schedule even when
natalie portman isn't necessarily
training for a role she knows how to
stay in shape in a 2019 interview with
women's help the mega star discussed how
she keeps up her strength even when her
schedule gets hectic and she described
it i run maybe three times a week when
i'm running for a full hour it feels a
little like meditation to me later she
discusses how she's a fan of a style of
exercise known as gyrotonics which
essentially consists of movements you'll
find with tai chi yoga gymnastics and
other disciplines all wrapped into one
convenient package ultimately it sounds
like she keeps an open mind and
exercises in whatever manner is most
convenient in the moment stating i used
to do ashtonga but now i'll just get
there and i'll try anything considering
the results we'd say this routine has
definitely worked well for her and what
portman has shared in public about her
training so far sounds brutal she went
on the tonight show starring jimmy
fallon to offer an update on thor love
and thunder and while shooting hadn't
started at the time portman was already
being put through the ringer and from
the sound of things she wasn't exactly
in the best place mentally to start an
intense regimen she told fallon i'm
trying i've had like months of like
pandemic you know eating baked goods and
like lying in bed and feeling sorry for
myself
i'm like super tired after working out
yeah and during yeah and dreading before
around that same time she also stopped
by watch what happens live with andy
cohen where she was asked if she had to
be on a workout plan similar to her
co-star chris hemsworth she said that
she was and she wasn't taking to it very
easily yes i am training and i'm in so
much pain like i'm not good at this
maddie black formerly a crossfit coach
with vogue fitness offered some of her
insight into how portman could
accomplish such gains in an interview
with allen live she said natalie will be
carrying out lots of compound
weightlifting movements such as
squatting pressing and pulling in order
to remain lean for the role she'll be
implementing some high-intensity
interval training into her weekly
routine she goes on to explain how she
would go about designing an exercise
regimen for someone wanting the kind of
arms jane foster's thor has in the
comics declaring weightlifting would
form the foundation base whilst
functional training would develop skills
improve flexibility and enhance
endurance we may not know exactly how
heavy her weights are but it's
definitely clear she's been pumping iron
in one way or another we didn't think
there was any way portman could look
more intimidating than in her natalie
raps video judging from those guns she
just proved this wrong
she's not a bird or a plane and she's
definitely not superman melissa benoit
is the cw supergirl but how did she get
ready for the part let's take a look at
how this self-proclaimed musical theatre
nerd got into fighting condition to play
the high-flying heart-punching supergirl
you don't just get handed a role like
supergirl melissa benoist had to go
through a rigorous audition process
before she got anywhere close to landing
the role the wait was made even more
excruciating because according to
benoist she was among the first actors
to audition for the parts the first
audition was in october 2014 and it was
just the start of what would become a
month-long process she told
entertainment weekly that she didn't
learn she landed the part until february
2015. in the interim she said
i went through multiple screen tests
multiple auditions with a producing team
there was a lot
during that extensive audition process
variety reported that benoit's found a
champion in producer greg berlanti but
noyce said greg championed me the whole
time and was in my corner even when i
didn't think the part was mine he was
always rooting for me that support goes
a long way especially when i'm fighting
for something i want so badly his belief
in me really touched me belanti echoed
the sentiment praising the supergirl
star by saying if we had not found her i
would have said i don't want to make
this the first episode aired almost a
year after that first audition on
october 26 2015. she's inhabited the
role ever since serving as an
inspiration for fans around the world
did now are there like a million little
girls that dress up as supergirl now as
a result of the show every halloween
they're they're quite a bit of supergirl
one thing that all superheroes have in
common are incredible abs and the noise
supergirl is no exception she said in
interviews that to prepare for the role
of cara zorrell she focused on both
strength training and core work
getting toned with a combination of
pilates boxing and player metrics if
you've never had a reason to get into
superhero shape you might be wondering
what player metrics are plyometrics
involve exerting your body to its
maximum ability for a short period of
time for example by jumping to improve
strength speed and power as benice found
out pilot routines are far from easy
work
did i did quite a bit of training we did
this stuff called plyometrics which is
like jump training and all of it was
really hard just hard things
all that focus on the core isn't just
for the sake of looking good it also
comes in handy when you're doing flying
stunts to do the flying
stunts you know i'm up in a wire and you
have to hold your entire body weight so
there's a lot of training involved
melissa benoist wasn't the only cast
member who had to upper workout
intensity to give the action sequences
the effort they deserved kyla lee who
plays cara's adoptive sister alex said
that the actors work really hard with
the stunt coordinators to get the fight
scenes just right and those
action-packed days are full on workouts
in their own right she told cbs watch
magazine when we do fight scenes we're
working out for six hours just doing the
same thing we are burnt for the next few
days i think that's where i really get
my caloric burn count even when they
aren't shooting liam benoit's tried to
use their periods of waiting around that
happen on the set of a tv show to stay
in shape she said melissa and i try to
do as much as we possibly can in my
trailer i've got resistance bands and
medicine balls and things like that i
try to do it in between but we have very
little down time the two on-screen
sisters also have a shared interest in
pilates which lisa says she fits into a
schedule when she can and you thought tv
sets were all hanging out in trailers
enjoying craft services
yes
another crucial element of being a
superhero is being able to convincingly
kick some villainous butt this didn't
come naturally to benoist who confessed
to the chicago tribune i had never
punched anyone i maybe slapped my
sisters when i was a kid but i am not an
aggressive violent person and i had no
idea how to throw a punch in order to
help herself find her in a fighter
benoice took a boxing she told instyle i
definitely had to learn technique like
how to actually punch someone and not
hurt yourself more than you're hurting
the person you're punching fortunately
for benoist she had access to excellent
tutors in addition to the stunt team
former karate and kickboxing world
champion lexi alexander directed an
episode in the first season her
directing stint was short bert alexander
told den of geek that she pushed her
star to the limit saying this was a
brand new thing for everybody involved
and everybody was excited that a real
fighter was getting melissa benoist to
the next level of fight choreography in
fact the change in bernoulli's technique
was so dramatic that alexander said the
series stunt team changed benoit's
fighting style going forward to
incorporate her expert tips so while
benjoyce might at heart still be more a
lover than a fighter we still wouldn't
want to challenge her to throw down at
this point i actually kind of love it
believe it or not it really is benoit's
doing some of those hair-raising stunts
on the show the actress told variety
that she likes to get involved with the
action when she can saying i have been
doing a lot of stunts and i want to keep
doing them supergirl's fight moves are
boxing she's really heavy-handed there's
some flying that involves kicking and
punching mid-flight that's kind of
awesome
however not everyone was thrilled with
benoit's hand on approach to fights her
mom julie told her that she found it
difficult to watch her daughter's fight
scenes especially against men but julie
benoist needn't have worried melissa
knows her limits and she's also heaped
praise on her stunt doubles in 2015 she
spoke to instyle on the subject of
stunts saying i think that's so fun
there are some that i just can't i
really could get injured
you should rest some more since when is
that ever works with me
glee was not benoit's first experience
with musical theater she said she's been
practicing the craft since she was four
years old attending classes in tap
ballet and jazz dance but she wasn't
always a perfect student especially in
ballet all years i took ballet class i
was the one kid in class that the
teacher was always like her turn out and
she's not standing up straight she did
better with another form of dance where
she showed off in a video for glamour i
have a secret superpower that i can tap
dance
that dance training came in handy on the
set of supergirl and not just for
benoit's part in the musical crossover
episode of the flash i have to say i'm
not impressed
by your more famous cousin
thank you no one ever says that bonoy
said that her dance background helps her
with the wire work and even the fight
sequences she told the chicago tribune
the wire work and flying even the
choreography kind of came like it would
if i were learning a dance routine it's
also a handy skill that keeps her and
the crew entertained between takes
melissa benoit's favorite thing about
her superhero role is exactly what you'd
expect the chance to fly seems like
flying wouldn't be so great when you're
pretending to fly yeah i mean it's hard
work i'm essentially like attached to a
fork in the air despite how some skilled
animators make it look on screen flying
isn't easy especially when you have to
act like it's all effortless to you but
noise told variety just how hard it was
and how she prepared saying the while
work for training is mostly core work
it's mostly abscentric the whole area of
the body that nobody wants to work out
you have to get strong you have to carry
your whole body weight when you're up in
the air however it's all worth all the
working out to make the process run
smoothly she told people the wire work
is really difficult but so fun and when
you get it right watching the result is
exhilarating it's a really really cool
feeling to know what it felt like the
energy i had to exert to create those
flying scenes and then the way it looks
is really rewarding but noyce got some
help perfecting her flying technique
when jimmy kimmel asked how she figured
out supergirl's flying style she had a
surprising answer in store there's sort
of this almost
superhero physicality school that you
kind of have to go to where the stunt
team will teach you like how to walk
like a superhero and that's how to look
flying spandex
all that working out and unset action
builds up an appetite but as a female
superhero who's expected to squeeze into
a tight superhero suit every day and
have the muscles to beat to bad guys
without actually looking all that bulked
up but noyce can't exactly go to town
and craft services fortunately she's
pretty into fruits and vegetables anyway
she gushed to glamour i love
supermarkets i love grocery shopping i
love the produce style because to be
super you have to be healthy
and i would probably stock up on all the
fruits however she isn't about to
totally deprive herself of comfort foods
in the same glamour interview she said
if i could supersize any food it would
be ice cream drumstick vanilla caramel
they're so good in 2016 she told the
chicago tribune that she was excited to
attend that year's chicago comic-con and
entertainment expo aka c2e2 not just to
commune with fellow artists and fans but
because she wanted to check out the
city's restaurants as she explained
quote i've heard the food scene is
incredible and i'm a foodie so i can't
wait to go out and eat bernoist also
said that her partiality to the
occasional junk food splurge inspired
the writers to add the habit into a
character's personality she said i love
junk food i love donuts and they put
that in there quite a bit
do you like donuts
it doesn't like donuts i know a place it
just goes to show that as long as you're
disciplined with your workouts you don't
have to deprive yourself of every treat
you love
one reason melissa benoist was so
invested in making sure her character
could be physically impressive on screen
was because she wanted to inspire other
women to feel strong and powerful in
their own lives in an essay for time she
wrote i think the more the show goes on
the more you see this fierceness and
what women are really capable of it puts
supergirl on this equal playing field
that's so meaningful to me to help
children understand that girls can have
just as much fun as their male
counterparts in the superhero world it's
about confidence and hope and supergirl
really embodies all of that even though
benoist also wrote that she grew up in a
quote really strong feminine family she
told the chicago tribune i didn't really
believe that i could be that character
or play a superhero it's something i
never thought of myself as doing but i
just knew i had to go for it because
there's so few female superheroes and
just strong females that fight back and
do it with grace and do it with love
she's also said that she doesn't want
the character to be a female version of
male superheroes saying what i think is
cool is to try to bring a kind of
femininity to her strength i do like the
idea of bringing in like a grace to it
and the fluidity and kind of this
femininity to flying it's fun in other
words melissa benoist is out here
bringing new meaning to supergirl power
previously known for starring in
effects's hit atlanta sarsi beats was as
surprised as anyone when she landed the
role of super lucky mutant domino in
deadpool 2. usa today called her a
captivating standout and vanity fair
proclaimed her the best thing about the
r-rated sequel she slipped into the role
like she was born to play it but getting
to that point required a lot of work
here's how beats got ripped for deadpool
2.
i am naturally
not one to
a first time for everything
beats never had to work out for her
roles in 2017's geostorm or atlanta
either but when she signed on to play
domino she knew it was going to require
her to hit the gym she told the
hollywood reporter in my routine day to
day i didn't really work out that much
so it was a huge transition emotionally
and physically i'd never really brought
myself that far and she revealed it
wasn't just physically exhausting
telling shadow and out the training ends
up becoming this mental and emotional
experience as well putting in the time
beats trained four hours a day for
months to get into shape before filming
began she told ibt i'm going to be
shooting guns i fight and a lot of that
movement is full body and physical
you're doing that for 12 hours a day and
they just want you to have the stamina
reflecting on the fatal onset accident
of a stunt woman joy harris beats also
revealed that leading man ryan reynolds
helped us stay focused telling
entertainment tonight it's amazing kind
of watching ryan do his thing he's
genuinely
incredibly talented
trainer to the stars
you might not know don saladino by name
but you've definitely seen his work
dubbed the superhero trainer saladino's
client list includes marvel star
scarlett johansson and sebastian stan
and wolverine's hugh jackman he's also
trained ryan reynolds and his wife blake
lively saladino began training reynolds
for deadpool 2 in february 2017 which
was how he became acquainted with beats
who admitted that she loved working with
saladino and the feeling was very much
mutual
becoming a superhero
after deadpool 2 hit theaters saladina
revealed to pop sugar that his first
thought when training beats was we had
to turn her into more of an ass kicker
saladino admitted that the style of
training he recommended for beets can
intimidate female clients but he said
picking up things like kettlebells and
doing things like squads and split
squats it's the stuff that works the
best it elevates the heart rate the most
and is not linear and so one dimensional
like how most people train
eating a vegan diet
because beets is vegan her diet didn't
really change all that much during a
deadpool 2 training but she told shadow
and act you have to change how you eat
and it also takes away your energy doing
that alongside shooting and prepping and
all that stuff it's a lot of work but it
was also really cool
crushing it
playing domino left its mark on beats
quite literally she told usa today that
she has a scar on her chest from a stray
shell that hit her during a shootout
scene she also passed out from
exhaustion in a leather bodysuit in the
middle of a fight sequence but despite
it all she says it was absolutely worth
it she told rte we had been working so
much and i was thinking hopefully it
will look good and i remember doing the
first take and then seeing the playback
and i was like it's [ __ ] amazing
for the iconic role of joker and suicide
squad jared leto got into incredible
shape and focused on building serious
muscle definition now he's hitting the
gym again to get ready to star as the
title character in the upcoming
spider-man spin-off film morbius
the personal training sessions for
suicide squad were no joke under the
guidance of trainer brandon johnston the
entire cast got fit together while
staying at a training facility in
toronto for what they described as boot
camp johnston had specific exercises in
mind for each cast member depending on
what their character would be doing on
screen according to men's journal
johnston wanted leto to look like an mma
fighter by the time he was done working
with him how did he achieve that for
starters leto's regular workouts
consisted of plenty of bodybuilding
exercises and weighted calisthenics he
also practiced boxing and johnston noted
that leto was quote throwing a lot of
punches throughout the day leto's
regular routines also included daily
cardio the cast typically got one day
off after every four days they spent in
the gym so there was also some mandatory
rest time
leto is living proof that you don't need
to eat meat in order to build muscle
according to an interview with gq leto
has been vegan for over two decades
clearly it's working out pretty well for
him as he credits his vegan lifestyle
for his health he does admit to cheating
every once in a while and indulging in
treats that contain milk or eggs but he
draws the line at consuming meat even on
special occasions a vegan chef comes on
tour with 30 seconds to mars even when
the band did their carnivores tour with
lincoln park leto was still fueling up
on fruits and vegetables backstage in
2014 he was named peta's sexiest vegan
to get ready to play the joker leto had
to eat every two hours throughout the
day to keep his energy up and his
metabolism working hard
so what's letto's number one fitness
secret his primary piece of advice is
something that seems so obvious yet many
people still underestimate its
importance when it comes to looking your
best letto told rolling stone i would
tell everyone to sleep as much as you
can with his crazy schedule he knows
that it's crucial to get that full 8
hours of sleep every night from concerts
to the gym to the recording studio to
the set of whatever film he's working on
he needs to be able to perform at his
best every moment of the day some people
assume that musicians and actors would
rather go out every night than crawl
into bed early but roletto this isn't
the case
it's easy to assume that an actor who
dives deeply into their roles like letto
might be experimenting with certain
substances off-screen after all he did
live on the street with addicts to
prepare for his role in requiem for a
dream but even then leto didn't partake
and he says that at this point he's been
totally straight edged for many years no
drugs or alcohol leto admitted to
getting into some trouble in his younger
days due to his previous alcohol and
drug use however he eventually changed
his ways and he knows that he made the
right choice he told rolling stone i
guess at some point too there's a
decision is this going to be my life i
made a choice to pursue other dreams the
risk versus reward is out of line i just
saw too many examples of what not to do
leto hasn't yet given any specific
details about his workouts for morbius
however he does post pretty frequently
on instagram so far it looks like he's
been working out on his elliptical and
he also says he's been going for daily
morning bike rides even while he's on
tour of course touring is a workout in
and of itself it's kind of like you know
a master
you know spinning aerobics class richard
simmons would be proud of course touring
is a workout in itself although he
hasn't posted about any bodybuilding
workouts yet he's most likely sticking
with a lifting routine as well rock
climbing is also one of leto's favorite
hobbies whether he's trying to get in
shape for a particular role or not he
always makes time to climb he told
rolling stone climbing is also a form of
stress relief for him and a way to stay
balanced in the chaotic world of
hollywood morbius isn't due out for
release until july 2020 with shooting
having commenced in march 2019 but you
can bet with his unmatched commitment to
his work leto is sure to deliver as the
star
landing a role in a superhero movie
comes with more than just a nice
paycheck and a steady work opportunity
actors are now expected to get in
superhuman shape for action roles and
margot robbie as harley quinn is no
exception here's how she got into havoc
wreaking shape
of course margot robbie is fully
dedicated to playing harley quinn now
but she originally got the role without
even having to convince anyone she
wanted it the actress told mtv news that
the team behind suicide squad approached
her with the role offering her the part
without even having to audition i
actually got offered this one i didn't
audition which is
a real step up as an actor when you can
get offered things as it turns out the
producers were captivated by robbie's
performance alongside will smith in the
2015 movie focus smith was already
locked in to play deadshot and suicide
squad wanted to recreate that connection
when they cast their harley quinn i
guess they knew that will and i worked
well together so that was a given we
didn't have to do like chemistry reads
or anything like that the studio's
gamble paid off and while the overall
reviews for suicide squad were less than
enthusiastic the dynamic between smith
and robbie was a consistent high point
of the film
you're my friend too
stay evil dog face
margot robbie is already in pretty great
shape thanks to working out four or five
times a week for an hour each session
according to hollywood personal trainer
andy hecker to get in fighting shape for
her comic book movie however she ramped
that up to three hours per day as part
of a ballet based fitness program that
hecker operates robbie worked out in
three hour blocks nearly every day for
three weeks while filming suicide squad
hecker told people magazine that the
focus on harley's body and her skimpy
costume pushed robbie to work out that
much harder according to hecker there's
a scene in suicide squad where she
changes clothes in front of a bunch of
dudes so her abs needed to be impeccable
and in those tiny shorts harley wears
her butt was constantly on display the
parts of robbie's body that were on
screen for most of suicide squad became
the focus of her tailored workouts
hecker came up with an exercise routine
that would transform robbie from a
glamorous starlet into the tough and
acrobatic harley quinn according to
hecker margot wanted to lean out and
tone up she's already slender but we
wanted to make her a little stronger to
achieve these goals most of robbie's
workout regimen consisted of non-bulking
cardio exercises like ballet jumps as a
former dancer who runs a ballet training
program hecker told people that the
jumps ballet dancers perform are quote
surprisingly the most challenging form
of cardio i have ever come across but
despite the relative difficulty of the
exercises hecker said that robbie rarely
ever faltered in her commitment to the
routine hecker compared robbie to a
machine when she spoke to the los
angeles times the actress's workouts
apparently resembled dance marathons
where other clients of heckers would
steadily throw in the towel while robbie
kept at it relentlessly hecker shared
that other people would try the workout
along with us but she kept going when
other people were dropping off it's so
challenging to keep up that level of
intensity but she powered through it
hecker also ran the actress through a
weightlifting regimen intended to tone
her butt thighs and legs she spoke of
robbie's workout on a granular level in
the lead-up to suicide squad's release
telling publications the exact types of
exercises robbie went through while
trying to embody harley quinn she said
that they went for a lower number of
reps with more weight a focus on form
and engaging the correct muscle groups
in an interview with the hollywood
reporter hecker explained she had to
look sexy and strong we'd do lower reps
so 20 leg lifts with that ankle weight
on and then take a break to move on to
the other leg to do another 20 making
sure her glutes were doing it and not
her hamstrings
if that robotic intensity is making you
feel like you'll never be able to attain
a form like margot robbie's don't worry
while hecker painted a picture of the
actress as an ultra dedicated workhorse
in the gym robbie herself revealed that
she is far from disciplined when it
comes to her diet in an interview with
emirates woman robbie admitted that she
can't handle calorie cutting diets and
that cutting delicious and fatty foods
from her life makes her miserable i'm
not good at doing moderation i can't
just have a salad every day and a half a
glass of wine every second day i can't
do it robbie told the publication that
her diet largely consisted of beer fries
and burgers which she burned off in the
gym she added that she has a rather
unhealthy way of cutting weight quickly
if a role calls for it saying if i have
to get in a bikini then i'll eat carrot
sticks for three days i'm one extreme or
the other
successfully pushing to get a standalone
harley quinn movie made meant that
robbie had to get back into suicide
squad shape in which she was able to
perform most of her own stunts according
to suicide squad co-producer andy
horwitz
margot does 97 of her stunts in this
movie she embraced everything we threw
at her she makes it her own and does it
better than we could have ever assumed
it was going to be however when it came
to revisiting harley for birds of prey
robbie said many of the stunts in the
new film were actually too dangerous to
take on there's a lot of really cool
stunts in the birds of parade movie
quite a few of them i couldn't do
because they were just too risky that's
not to say that robbie slacked off in
comparison to her work for suicide squad
though in addition to her regular
workouts robbie trained to roller skate
ahead of birds of prey after already
learning to ice skate for her role in i
tonya photos of robbie training and
shooting in roller skates circulated on
comic book blogs ahead of the movie's
release revealing that prey will be
based on a later version of harley quinn
modeled after roller derby players
the roller skating harley quinn comes
from the new 52 reboot in the dc
universe which remodeled many characters
with a hard refresh of 52 titles even a
newish character like quinn was not
immune from the mandate the most recent
version of quinn has been completely
removed from the joker as she finally
split with the clown prince of crime for
good with her newfound independence
quinn's motivations have also shifted
where before most of her actions could
be explained as working for mr j the
newly single quinn is considerably less
villainous she's become a sort of
anti-heroic vigilante toeing the line
between criminal and superhero while
attempting to hold her home of coney
island together the new quinn is in the
mold of wise cracking weirdos with murky
morals like deadpool and screenwriter
christina hodgson even cited the merc
with a mouth when she talked about her
early talks with margot robbie around
the film robbie's dedication to the
character is bound to translate to the
big screen once again as it did in
suicide squad and considering that birds
of prey's reviews are a big improvement
over the reaction to suicide squad it's
likely that we will be seeing robbie as
a ripped harley quinn for years to come
as sam wilson aka the falcon anthony
mackie plays a lean mean mcu fighting
machine even before his debut in captain
america the winter soldier mackie has
pretty much been in exceptional shape so
how did he get so ripped we've got all
the details
anthony mackie threw his hat into the
marvel ring in the early 2010s but it
would be a while before he got the suit
up as the falcon in that time he made a
movie with two of the most ripped actors
in hollywood mark wahlberg and the rock
himself dwayne johnson mackie had to hit
the weights hard for his role in michael
bay's painting game which was very
loosely based on a real-life kidnapping
executed by some ham-fisted bodybuilders
in the 1990s by mackie's own admission
he was quote lazy and fat when he landed
the part of steroid using meathead
adrian doorball telling buzzfeed i was
looking for a project to help me get
back in the gym and start working out
and i'm sitting down
curling twinkies and watching prices
right every morning mackie was given
just five weeks to get in shape for the
shoot to make that happen he started a
regimen of heavy lifting and no cardio
he told men's health i was max reppie i
was doing chest and thighs back and
tries and shoulders and then friday
would be legs and i would start over
again it was just constantly ripping the
muscle giving it four days to recover
and then going right back into it
to help him get ripped for pain and gain
mackie enlisted the help of an old
workout buddy back in his hometown of
new orleans he told buzzfeed we would
just push each other every day then once
the movie started mark and i would work
out every morning together mackie has
spoken at length about what it was like
having mark wahlberg as a workout
partner for the duration of the shoot he
revealed that the musician turned
hollywood star quotes can be very
difficult at times but he doesn't hold
that against him telling vibe the thing
about mark is that he is the ultimate
competitor i thought that i was
competitive but he's a definite rival in
my level of competitiveness
that's it
work harder keeping up with wahlberg and
his iron pumping entourage proved to be
quite the challenge but it did absolute
wonders for the soon-to-be marvel star's
physique they spent around six weeks as
gym buddies and mackie noticed some
extreme gains in that time saying we
would push each other to the limits and
max out it was a great opportunity to be
in the gym and just become a gym head
like i was in high school once again
mackie's dream of joining the mcu became
a reality when he won the role of the
falcon and captain america the winter
soldier but he quickly realized that he
was going to look tiny next to the super
jack to chris evans the hard work he did
before and during the making of pain and
gain had him in impressive shape but
this was another level entirely
don't say it don't you say
come on
after news of his casting broke mackie
told vulture chris evans is in such good
shape i'm just a duty dragged into the
lab that he injected with some but i
gotta stand next to him so we shall see
at that point everything maki knew about
the falcon came from the comics and they
made for a pretty daunting read
describing sam wilson a harlem born
orphan who becomes captain america's
partner after the latter freezed his
mind from the control of the red skull
mackie said he's known for his physique
he's described as 6'3 245 pounds so
starting monday for the next five months
until we start shooting i'm going back
to high school workouts and start doing
two-a-days so i get up to 230 pounds he
may not look quite as jacked as evans
does in captain america the winter
soldier but by the time they reunited to
shoot avengers age voltron mackie was
apparently doing more push-ups than even
cap himself
every superhero actor wants to look
their best when they pull on their
costume and anthony mackie is no
exception a competitive person by nature
he instinctively started comparing
himself to chris evans after joining the
cast of captain america the winter
soldier though he knew that sam wilson
isn't a super soldier like cap this
meant that he had to toe a fine line
between looking super jacked and
superhuman he told vibe i wanted to put
myself in a position where i don't look
like mr t but you can tell that the guy
works out and pays attention to his
physique and is healthy i've been in the
gym and worked out long enough to know
how to get results with my body he got
those results with the aid of some good
old-fashioned shut-eye and a carefully
considered diet oh hi guess what i'm
doing i'm cooking to this day the actor
is very particular about what he eats
while he's bulking up when he sat down
with men's health in 2021 he revealed
that his personally designed meal plan
helps him to quote lean out for the
camera
i find that because i lift heavy i tend
to bulk easily so i try to use my diet
to cut as much fat as possible
coffee has long been america's favorite
source of caffeine but all joe has had a
new rival in recent years energy drinks
have become a popular alternative to
more expensive pre-workout beverages
with one study from the journal of the
international society of sports
nutrition revealing that 42 percent of
athletes chug one as part of their
regiment mackie has never been
interested though telling men's health
i'm not really really big on pre-workout
or energy drinks i feel like i don't
need the boost so i try to drink as much
water as possible before and after going
to the gym it does however partake in
another favorite of bodybuilders
everywhere the protein shake the actor
began consuming a shake after every
workout during his painting game days
telling buzzfeed i would do half a
banana a scoop of peanut butter and a
scoop of protein with skim milk and make
a smoothie and he's been fine-tuning his
recipe ever since nowadays he's less
about the peanuts and more about the
almond telling men's health i do a scoop
of vegan-based protein a tablespoon of
powdered almond butter so it cuts all
the sugar out of it i do almond milk and
almond water he also uses collagen and
turmeric which he claims helps with
elasticity and joint repair my big thing
now is a collagen
mackie got used to getting up early to
eat back when he was working out with
mark wahlberg telling the pittsburgh
post gazette that he would have six egg
whites and an egg yolk for breakfast at
six a.m speaking of honey and lime about
the strict diet he followed for captain
america the winter soldier mackie said
you know fitness is a lifestyle you have
to eat a certain way you have to do a
certain thing you have to live a certain
way the falcon still has eggs in the
morning but he cooks them up nowadays
mackie told men's health that his quote
real simple breakfast is usually made up
of six scrambled eggs with sauteed
onions or sweet peppers he also has a
portion of steel-cut oats a breakfast
favorite among bodybuilders adding this
deal cut oats is very important because
my body uses those carbs to burn off
when i work out in the morning because i
like to work out early that's the
breakfast i have every day
from the moment he gets up in the
morning to the end of the day mackie is
quote constantly grazing in the kitchen
telling mentel i'll nibble and bite and
eat throughout the course of the day so
i never feel full but i never feel empty
that doesn't mean he skimps on the
portions at meal time however he follows
up his egg and oat breakfast with a
quote pretty big lunch that's full of
everything he needs to keep his
superhero bod according to mackie that
includes two or three grilled chicken
cutlets some cut vegetables with hummus
and a salad i try to have my
big meals in the middle of the day
instead of later the extra food he puts
away at lunch time gives him the energy
he needs to carry on until the evening
when he does a three mile 30 minute run
to get the blood pumping it's more
functional than it is tasty but that's
all part of the gig
maggie got used to saying goodbye to the
naughty things in his life when he was
preparing for captain america the winter
soldier joking to honey and lime me and
my homeboy jack daniels stopped talking
me and my girlfriend haagen-dazs broke
up she french it was crazy so it goes
for those who want to portray
superheroes
mackie's fellow marvel star chris
hemsworth has proven that it's perfectly
possible to achieve a godlike body while
on a plant-based diet the thor actor
shocked everyone his own personal
trainer included when he managed to
maintain his incredible physique after
going vegan there's a lot to be said for
vegan superheroes but that's not how
macky rolls the actor revealed to men's
health that he's a big meat lover saying
dinner is usually a big piece of fish or
a piece of chicken i try to stay with
lean protein i'm really into bison and
buffalo now if i have to have red meat
or lamb which is my favorite meat on
earth he went on to reveal that every
now and then he'll visit his favorite
butcher in search of quote something
wild to spice things up like rabbits or
something like that becky pairs his meat
with either brown rice or quinoa saying
quinoa is really big for me now so i'll
do that and make a quinoa veggie saute
after debuting as the falcon and captain
america the winter soldier anthony
mackie went on to reprise the role in
avengers age of ultron ant-man captain
america civil war avengers infinity war
and avengers end game by the time it
came to film end game he had his fitness
regimen down to an art when the actor
sat down for a video interview with
vanity fair right after the release of
the multi-billion dollar grossing sequel
in 2019 he walked viewers through his
typical day
i wake up to beyonce i do i love beyonce
she makes me strong
she's my spirit adam after that he eats
his protein-packed breakfast and that's
when the hard work begins according to
the actor the first thing i do in the
morning is 100 push-ups around 7 30 am
he hits the gym mackie also shared a big
workout hack instead of driving himself
to the gym and warming up there he runs
the four miles instead leaving him with
more time for weights get in i'm already
warm from the jog mackie says he always
begins with 30 minutes of legs then we
move on to other places monday is chest
and try tuesday we'll be back in biceps
every day you hit abs for 20 minutes and
then wednesday would be legs and
shoulders burn them out start the
routine over
at this point atlanta is a second home
to marvel stars like anthony mackie at
least a dozen mcu movies have made use
of pinewood atlanta studios and the
atlanta metro area has doubled for
everywhere from new york city to lagos
disney plus series the falcon and the
winter soldier was also filmed in
atlanta and when mackie wasn't on the
job he liked to slip into his favorite
pair of cycling shorts and find some
exercise bikes he told gq
you have a lot of different cycling
places you have the cycling places in
buckhead where you have a lot of young
women with ponytails that'll scream and
are very angry on their bikes or you can
go to the cycling place in decatur where
there are a lot of young angry people
who yell and twerk on bikes yes it's
true i like to listen to rhythmic music
and lift weights while i ride bikes for
long distances against young women yes
mackie particularly likes getting his
bike fixed in midtown where it's
apparently a lot more easy going he said
it's just a bunch of nice people that
ride bikes no one's yelling no one's
throwing stuff everyone's sweating the
cycling along with all of mackie's tried
and tested routines reportedly had him
in the best shape of his life as he shot
the falcon and the winter soldier
when kumail nanjiani was cast in
marvel's eternals he was determined to
step up his game to play the samurai
king go soon and challenged himself to
look the part here are the secrets the
star and his personal trainer grant
roberts have revealed behind his bulking
up journey after seeing kumail
nanjiani's photos of his physical
transformation plenty of people wondered
how he got those incredible results and
if they could potentially recreate his
success on their own however nanjiani
has been open about the fact that his
results would not have been possible if
he wasn't in a position of immense
privilege he worked with personal
trainers and nutritionists throughout
the year all of whom were focused on
creating a custom program for his body
goals and lifestyle nanjiani wrote in
his instagram caption i would not have
been able to do this if i didn't have a
full year with the best trainers and
nutritionists paid for by the biggest
studio in the world i'm glad i look like
this but i also understand why i never
did before it would have been impossible
without these resources in time
over the course of his fitness journey
kumail nanjiani worked with many top
personal trainers and nutritionists all
of whom played an important role in
helping him achieve his goals but he
spent most of his time training with
grant roberts who has also worked as an
actor you might have spotted him in
sully or in films like million dollar
baby being in front of the camera
himself meant that he understood exactly
what nanjiani needed to do in order to
prepare for eternals roberts told page
six my process is completely
individualized and starts with the
gathering of information current
lifestyle body composition tests etc i
also have a 3d scanner that's
particularly useful for goal setting and
strategizing the nutrition and training
program the 3d body scanner that robits
uses probably doesn't come cheap but
these machines create accurate pictures
of his client's body composition posture
and how their measurements change as
they work out it was an invaluable tool
for creating nanjiani's training program
he scares me too but he's an excellent
motivator
that's true what are you looking at
so if you want to get muscles like
nanjiani how often do you have to hit
the gym nanjiani generally worked out
for a little over an hour four to five
days a week however recovery time was an
important component of his fitness
program he consistently took two or
three days off each week many people
think that they need to push themselves
to work out without taking a day off if
they want to bulk up or lose weight but
having scheduled rest days so that your
muscles can heal is actually crucial
roberts definitely wanted nanjiani to
commit to a rigorous workout schedule
but as a professional trainer he also
understood that regular rest days would
be the key to long-term success spending
time relaxing outside of the gym is just
as important as spending time in the gym
they say that abs are made in the
kitchen and this was definitely true for
nanjiani getting fit wasn't just about
burning calories in the gym he also had
to ensure that he was fueling his body
with healthy foods sure you can
technically lose weight while eating
sugary desserts or savory comfort foods
but when it comes to building muscle you
need to start with the right building
blocks and put nutritious foods on your
plate what was included in anjani's food
pyramid he went with the low-carb
approach to dieting he also made sure to
eat plenty of protein which is essential
for building muscle and having a
sustained source of energy for workouts
nanjiani also focused on adding healthy
fats to his diet particularly sources of
omega-3 fatty acids in addition he made
sure to drink plenty of water and stay
hydrated if you're exercising as often
as he was you don't want to forget your
water bottle when you go to the gym
many people find that sticking to a
consistent healthy diet is even more
difficult than finding a form of
exercise they enjoy but for kumail
nanjiani this wasn't the case he was so
dedicated to his fitness program that he
didn't want to take cheat days in fact
one of the nutritionists he worked with
basically had to force him to take a day
off from his diet and indulge every once
in a while nanjiani credits david
higgins for giving him permission to
enjoy his favorite foods and stop being
so hard on himself what did nanjiani
reach for on cheat days he grew up in
pakistan and he loves pakistani food but
he admits that this cuisine is very carb
heavy which meant that it wasn't
appropriate for his usual meal planning
but he says that traditional pakistani
food like biryani non-bread and rice was
his quote go-to cheat meal and he would
often feel so full after eating it that
he had to take a nap afterwards
when roberts designed nanjiani's workout
program he had a philosophy in mind no
weak spots yes they would target certain
muscles but overall he wanted to create
full body workouts his goal helped
nanjiani look like a real bodybuilder he
encouraged najiyani to concentrate on
the symmetry of the musculature so that
he would see improvements all over
roberts admits that he pushed nanjiani
in a way that he had never been pushed
before but nanjiani was always up for
the challenge robert says that nanjiani
was genuinely enthusiastic about getting
fit telling men's journal i was excited
to work with kumail because i could tell
he was ready to dedicate himself to the
process i have literally thousands of
text messages to prove that point
getting these kinds of results doesn't
happen without maximum effort
when it comes to helping his clients
roberts clearly likes to stay on the
cutting edge and utilize new technology
in the world of fitness while working
with nanjiani roberts regularly used
electric stimulation or e-stem to target
certain muscles the average gym goer may
not have used this tool but apparently
celebrity trainers like roberts are big
fans so how does electric stimulation
work basically roberts would place pads
hooked up to electric wires on
nanjiani's back over specific muscle
groups sometimes he would deliver a zap
which helped quote fire up the muscles
it may sound strange but roberts is a
fan of using this method with clients he
used electric stimulation with nanjiani
about twice per week
when you start working out and eating
healthy you don't see results overnight
the waiting game is frustrating but it
takes a while to notice the results you
really want however according to roberts
non gianni really didn't have to wait
long to see results this is because
roberts went right in with workouts that
were focused on intensity packing lots
of action into a short time frame this
leads to fast muscle building and weight
loss which was probably quite motivating
for nanjiani roberts told page six
kumail responded very quickly as most
people do when introduced to training
that shocks the system whether it be for
fat loss or muscle gain or as in
kumail's case both
when nanjiani started working out to get
ready for eternals he felt like he had
spent years holding himself back from
his full potential he had generally
worked in comedy he was best known for
silicon valley in the big set but he
knew if he wanted to try something
different he would need to transform his
physique he had no idea just how strong
he could get because he had never tried
to figure out what his physical limits
were at one point he was getting so
muscular that marvel told roberts and
nanjiani to scale back and slow down a
bit apparently he looked quote too big
and too cut for the roll therefore
roberts lightened up on nanjiani's
workouts this probably wasn't the kind
of feedback that nanjiani expected from
the studio but it had to be flattering
how'd you feel
the key to seeing amazing results in the
gym isn't just physical exercise it's
also about your mindset kumail nanjiani
said that his perspective and sheer
level of concentration on his goals were
necessary to achieve the look he wanted
he told men's health when i'm exercising
i'm not thinking about anything else
it's like meditation nanjiani even
admitted that some of his friends were
dismayed by his new attitude towards
working out he says that at one point
they essentially quote staged an
intervention to get him out of the gym
for a few days they were worried that
his intense focus on working out would
detract from his skills as a comedian
nanjiani knew that outlook might affect
his work on funnier projects but he said
that in the end he didn't care i'm kind
of obsessed with it being funny wasn't
his only priority anymore he was ready
for a major change and he was willing to
accept the sacrifices that would come
along with it
in order to achieve the results he
really wanted nanjiani's nutritionist
basically had to micromanage his diet he
had to be exceptionally careful about
eating sugar and whenever he ate
something sweet he had to give them a
heads up so they could plan his meals
accordingly nanjiani told men's health
they were like if you're going to have a
can of coke today let us know in the
morning so we can adjust and account for
it although he was allowed to enjoy
cheat days he soon found that after
eating such a clean diet all week long
going on a sugar binge during the
weekends would hold him back when he
returned to the gym nanjiani admitted
that on one particular occasion he
decided to indulge in sticky toffee
pudding but came to regret it the next
day saying that he felt so quote off
that he had to endure 12 hours of
physical pain he eventually got so
strict with his sugar intake that he
ended up going an entire year without
eating even a single brownie
there's a common mistake that people
make when they begin working out they
try to go all out and adopt some extreme
habits which inevitably don't stick as a
personal trainer roberts is well aware
of these pitfalls and he was determined
to help nanjiani avoid them instead
roberts made sure that nanjiani was
developing habits that would be
sustainable in the long term even after
he dialed back on his original intense
training schedule roberts told the
hollywood reporter we sent him away in
peak physical condition but he's had to
maintain that i give him kudos for being
able to do that especially when he was
working it looks like the new nanjiani
is here to stay he's come a long way
throughout this journey and there's no
doubt that his skills will impress
audiences when eternals premieres
we took an in-depth look at the fitness
regimens employed by some of your
favorite marvel stars with an emphasis
on the diets and workouts they used
leading up to the mcu's big showdown
against thanos
lupita nyong'o is a relative newcomer to
the mcu her first marvel film was 2018's
black panther and she put in a lot of
work to get in shape we had six weeks of
boot camp where they you know got us all
bluff and
and ready to go fortunately she enjoyed
the physical challenge nyong'o said it's
just gaining strength stamina and
flexibility i had to get into
particularly good shape to be able to do
the stunts the boot camp worked and her
physical skill as nakia is evident it's
easy to imagine that her workout routine
for avengers endgame rests on continuing
to train hard and put on muscle
karen gillan debuted as nebula in the
guardians of the galaxy franchise before
appearing in infinity war and end game
and she didn't skimp as she prepared for
the role squats barbell deadlifts and
other weightlifting moves played a big
role in her workout routine cardio like
running and cycling upped her endurance
so she could last during the long days
on set next came martial arts training
as gillen put it i had to start from
scratch in terms of learning how to
fight to look like i could do damage to
someone finally she transformed her diet
eating protein shakes apples and almond
butter all helped gillen get the protein
she needed in order to build more muscle
and step into the role of nebula
it's not ripe
chris pratt better known as star-lord to
marvel fans took to instagram to share
his avengers infinity war workout in the
videos on his instagram stories pratt
took a three-mile trail run as a warm-up
and then did three sets of 120-yard hill
sprints pratt went through an intensive
training regimen for guardians of the
galaxy working for three or four hours
each day and losing 60 pounds in just
six months during that time pratt also
gave up alcohol ate 4 000 calories a day
in a low carb diet and did swimming
boxing p90x running kickboxing and even
a triathlon as part of his workout
routine so when it came time to prepare
for infinity war and end game pratt was
prepared he knew what it would take and
it seems like pratt enjoys his workouts
too i can do 40 inch box jumps now
action hero physical stuff jumping that
high feels really good when you get in
shape the world around you becomes
things you want to jump on and climb on
oh my god are you okay
yeah
i'm good
when josh brolin first started preparing
to play cable and deadpool 2 he went the
low carb route right away no sugar no
bread no pastas it can be a difficult
diet to follow but it's also one that
can produce results that is much evident
by watching brolin as thanos in avengers
infinity war in addition to exercising
his self-control in the kitchen brolin
put in the work in the gym too gold's
gym according to the location on some of
his instagram workout videos brolin
performed drop sets and other workout
moves with his trainer justin david
lovato of built nutrition and training
he's definitely put in the work and
although he can now enjoy his role as
thanos that role came at a heavy price
what did it cost
[Music]
everything
can you picture iron man doing yoga that
suit would definitely make it difficult
but in real life robert downey jr is an
ardent enthusiast in 2008 downey
described his infatuation with yoga
telling time i need a lot of support
life is really hard i've just been at
the ready and when the opening was there
i hid it downey was in the news for an
assortment of dangerous behaviors many
years ago and he said yoga is a big part
of what helped him improve his overall
health and wellness and stay on the
straight and arrow it is robert downey
wow
that's rdj yoga isn't a shocking or
particularly exciting workout it doesn't
make headlines like some of the other
intense regimens other marvel actors put
themselves through but downey doesn't
stop there either i train uh kung fu i
strength train i do chi gong i do susan
uh downey's workout is tracy anderson
by now we're pretty deep into the marvel
universe more than 20 movies deep in
fact and many of marvel's primary actors
have been around for a while that's why
they continue working out all year long
even if they aren't training for any
specific film chris hemsworth in
particular maintains a consistent
workout routine to stay in shape for
playing thor when it's time to really
gear up for his next mcu adventure he
can pack on as much as 20 pounds but in
between movies he keeps going to the gym
albeit at a more low key level there's
no reason for the cast to keep up their
punishing six day a week workout
schedule if they aren't preparing to
film but continuing some sort of
consistent exercise can help them stay
healthy and also stay prepared by
keeping up with workouts they won't have
as much work to do in order to get back
into fighting shape for the next movie
the other funny thing about doing these
kind of you know genre action movies is
you don't want to be
the tubby guy
through focusing on year-round fitness
staying in shape all the time so they'll
be ready for the next marvel film some
of the mcu stars have developed a
life-altering affinity for healthy
living chris hemsworth has even launched
a health fitness and diet app which
helps subscribers set goals and then
complete short focused workouts to reach
them mindfulness training nutrition
general health and well-being and
thought wouldn't it be cool if i could
bring all those people together into one
space and give you guys access to that
team like the rest of us the mcu cast
isn't getting any younger and a
persistent focus on regular exercise and
sensible nutrition is always a great way
to stay in shape whether you're simply
staying healthy or gearing up for a
blockbuster movie like avengers end game
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one